I have a Apple stock that I invested in
many years ago and I have a good wealth
since we've been in Apple stock we've
tripled since we started I also do have
just um a house that we just bought um
and so we're paying on that and two cars
is what we have uh no other debt so our
first goal is going to be to clear those
car payments what do you owe on your
cars it's about uh 16,000 and 18,000 wow
now how much do you have an Apple stock
what is it valued at today if you cash
it in 21,000 excellent okay all right
this is going to jar your system can you
hold on to your chair for a second
because I'm getting ready to knock you
out of the chair okay here we go you
ready for the ride Ready set go here we
go you ready oh my just be be kind I'm
gonna be kind but it's G to scare the
crap out of you are you ready I'm
cashing in the Apple stock and the
20,000 and paying off my cars today